Hey guys, welcome to my channel. Thank
you guys for watching. Today, what we're
working on is a 2012 Honda Civic
twodoor. This is what the customer gave
me. We're going to go ahead
and install and activate and program
this
XHorse remote key. So, we're going to go
ahead and put this key inside this
vehicle. Let's get this video started.
All right. Since we do have an original
key, I went ahead and put it together.
still broken. Put it on the on position.
Then we're going to go to
emo. Then we're going to auto VIN this
vehicle. And that's what it's doing.
It's auto detecting. Since the ignition
is on, uh the Autel 508 will go ahead
and recognize the vehicle. Pick up the
VIN. Get the right one. Hit okay. It's a
blade key.
Then we got the information
correct. So, we're accessing the system.
I like to do a EMO status scan just to
check the health of the vehicle. Making
sure that if there's any DTC, see what's
going on. Making sure that everything's
okay.
All right. Fourth blade key system. Pick
that
up. All right. Number of keys. If you
can see there, it's scanning the
vehicle, giving you the
information. Three keys. System is
normal. We're going to go and add a key
since we have one. So, let's go ahead
and start this function. Enter the
register key and turn the ignition on.
So, that's what we did
already. So, now bypassing the security
system, turn the ignition off within 15
seconds. Turn the ignition on using a
registered key. the same
key. All right. Turn the ignition
off. Insert the new
key. And turn the ignition
on. Okay.
So, there's the new key. And that's the
Xorse. Turn the ignition off.
Turn the ignition on using the same
key. Turn the ignition
off. Please turn the ignition
on. Establishing vehicle
connection. Did the immobilizer lamp go
out? If you could see there on the dash,
there's no immobilizer
light. So, did it go out? Yes.
Turn the ignition
off. Turn the ignition
[Music]
on. So, red key number. Now it's four. I
went ahead and registered this key.
That's how easy it is to go ahead and
add a key with the Autel 508S on this
2012 Honda Civic
twodoor. All right. So, after we want to
check if everything's working. So, if
you could see
there, it went ahead and programmed
everything. It's
locking. So, I'm going to go ahead and
turn on the vehicle. Make sure there's
no
lights. So, if you can see
there, everything works perfect.
Everything works as
normal. So, that's how easy it is.